(calm electronic music)
- Hey, come on in!
(upbeat music)
Yes, Push & Believe, you got it!
Can I get you some water,
a Zima, a Kirkland flat?
Brody, you've researched me.
I know I have.
It's easy to find you, I
just type it in on Bing.
Bing, yes!
Hangover one, in it,
Hangover II, in it.
Due Date, in it.
Funny People, let me guess,
you were cut out of it.
How did you know?
Because I'm you.
What?
That's right, Brody,
I'm in your head.
Really?
Did you take your
Lamictal last night?
How do you know I'm on Lamictal?
Cause all you do
is talk about it.
Really?
Yes!
It's amazing that we connect.
You know what, I know.
I am preparing for a
half hour comedy special,
and I know it's gonna go well.
It did go well, I'm
from the future.
Are you serious?
You got it.
Is there anything that you
don't like about yourself?
I don't like the way
I appear on camera,
and I gotta get over that.
You do, and I wanna get over it,
and that's why I'm
meditating, I'm doing yoga,
I'm doing therapy, I'm
walking the stairs.
Yeah, I don't wanna have the
ailments that my father had.
Exactly, I didn't
wanna go there,
but you did lose your father
at a point in your life
where maybe you needed him.
Yeah.
(sniffs) I promised
myself I wouldn't cry.
I understand what you're
going through, Brody.
What I didn't share
with my father,
I share with my mother.
I feel that connection with you.
Like, she was there
with me for Conan.
I know that, Brody, I watched
season one of Enjoy It!.
You had HBO GO?
Yes, I have an iPad.
Really?
You know, I'm very good
online, I have AppleCare.
You have AppleCare?
Who gets AppleCare?
I got it, you know why?
Because I care.
You do care.
Exactly, Brody,
that's what I do.
You've walked me through
a lot of things today.
Yeah, you grew, I know you
have adult onset autism.
How dare you do that to me?
That's my secret!
Well, you know what?
It's on Wikipedia.
Take it down, I can't take it,
I can, and then they
can put it back up.
It's open for
everybody to add it.
Really?
Yeah, I know that
about Wikipedia.
Okay, then why don't you
follow me on Twitter?
Cause I'm not into it
anymore, I do Vine.
What, don't get aggressive.
I wouldn't do that, Dr.
Tabori would be upset.
Dr. Tabori?
Yeah, she's my therapist.
Steven, I get emotional, Brody,
twice I charged a
mound in T-Ball.
(laughs) That's a funny joke.
I follow up, I don't just
quit when I'm feeling good.
You know what, I made
that mistake one time.
I was feeling good, and I,
too, got off my meds, you did?
Yes, I did.
And what happened?
I had an episode.
But you're better now?
I am better now,
I have structure.
And because of that,
you and I will crush
at Comedy Central's
half-hour, yearly taping.
You got it, Brody.
No, you got it, Steven.
Push
& Believe?
Yeah!
You got it, alright, one
more time, for safety.
Three, two, one,
Push & Believe!
Whew!
Pretty good, right?
That was okay.
Hold that thought.
We'll be right back
with the Steven Brody
Stevens Interview.
(bell dings)